ينضم الينا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره
الياس كران الذي يرصد الوضع في المناطق
الجنوبيه تحديدا من قطاع غزه
الياس نعم حسن وما زلنا نسمع في الساعه
الاخيره بطبيعه الحال القصف المدفعي الذي
يستهدف تحديدا المناطق الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه
منطقه خان يونس التي تشهد الزخم الاكبر
للعمليات العسكريه بحسب توصيف الجيش
الاسرائيلي يترافق ذلك ايضا مع تحليق كثيف
بين الحين والاخر للطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه التي تغير على مناطق بعينها
في الجهه الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه بالاضافه الى
تحليق ايضا للمروحيات العسكريه من ناو
اباتشي التي تكاد لا تغادر سماء هذه
المنطقه ونحن نرى ايضا في سماء المنطقه
منذ نحو ساعه
واكثر هذه الطائره التي يبدو انها طائره
استطلاعيه وت حوم في اجواء المنطقه على
شكل دائري كهذا الذي نراه الان بعدسه
الزميل لبيب واضح بان هذا النوع من
الطائرات يوفر ايضا معلومات استخباراتيه
مهمه كما يبدو للجيش الاسرائيلي على الارض
في المناطق الوسطى والجنوبيه لقطاع غزه
ذلك ان هذه الطائره تحلق منذ اكثر من ساعه
في حركه دائريه كالتي نراها الان من من
فوقنا وا هي يبدو انها توفر معلومات
استخباراتيه للقوات الاسرائيليه على الارض
وفي ميدان المعركه ويبدو انها ربما ايضا
ترصد تحركات بعينها للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه في منطقه خانيونس والمناطق
التي تشهد هذه المعارك ن نرى كيف تقوم هذه
الطائره
بحركه دائريه في اجواء المنطقه وكانها
تحوم حول هدف ما او تستطلع شيئا ما في
نقطه بعين ها في قطاع غزه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بان عملياته متواصله في
المنطقه الجنوبيه وهي تتعمق طيله الوقت
وتتركز فوق الارض وتحتها كما يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي في اشاره الى ان القوات
الاسرائيليه تعمل ايضا في داخل الانفاق
الهجوميه لكن واضح بان العمليه العسكريه
في المنطقه الجنوبيه في خانيونس تسير بحذر
شديد وبع نهايه شديده ذلك ان كل التوقعات
والتقديرات الاستخباراتيه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وكذلك تلك الاستخبارات
الموجوده لدى جهاز الامن الداخلي المعروف
بالشباك تشير الى ان المحتجزين
الاسرائيليين في داخل قطاع غزه موجودين في
تلك المنطقه تحديدا لذلك العمليات
العسكريه تسير ببطء وبحذر شديد من اجل عدم
ايذاء الاسرى الاسرائيليين في تلك المناطق
وهذا ما يشدد عليه المتحدث العسكري الرسمي
دائما في بياناته العسكريه عندما يتحدث عن
هذه المنطقه على وجه الخصوص وعندما يتحدث
وزير الدفاع يو اف جلنت بالامس عن توسيع
العمليه العسكريه في المنطقه الجنوبيه هو
يقصد ربما وصول القوات الاسرائيليه في
منطقه خانيونس الى احياء والى مناطق لم
يصلها في خلال العمليه العسكريه في تلك
المنطقه في الايام والاسابيع الاخيره وليس
بالضروره توسيع الى منطقه رفح لان الجيش
الاسرائيلي لا يبدو انه على الاقل في هذه
المرحله قادر على الانتقال من منطقه
خانيونس الى منطقه رفح لسبب ان هنالك
كثافه سكانيه فلسطينيه يضاف اليها بطبيعه
الحال نحو مليون فلسطيني نزحوا قصرا من
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه وهم موجودون
في تلك المنطقه ويبدو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
ايضا ما زال مترددا في القيام بعمليه
عسكريه في رفح او في منطقه محور فيلادلفيا
هذه المنطقه الواقعه على الحدود ما بين
قطاع غزه وال الجانب المصري من الحدود
باعتبار ان تحرك عسكري اسرائيلي في تلك
المنطقه بحاجه الى موافقه وتنسيق مع
السلطات المصريه ولا يبدو ان هنالك اي
مؤشر من الجانب ال المصري بسماح للسماح
الاسرائيل بالعمل عسكريا في تلك المنطقه
لذلك هنالك من يعتقد بان ثمه خطه ربما تج
بلورتها من اجل الامتناع عن القيام بعمليه
عسكريه في منطقه رفح وفي منطقه محور
فيلادلفيا لكن مقابل تدابير امنيه مشدده
فوق الارض وتحتها بتمويل من الاداره
الامريكيه ويبدو ان هذا الموضوع يدرس الان
مع الجانب المصري ليكون بديلا عن تحرك
عسكري اسرائيلي في تلك المناط شكرا لك
الياس كرام حدثنا من غلاف
غزه